you know this Alyssa Pharaoh chicks so
this is the girl who pretends to be a
conservative on The View and you know
they sort of like half-assedly pretend
that they like her but they'll wreck her
one day when they need to get rid of her
that's how it is uh she tweeted this out
about the uh the Disney situation she
wrote the development deal Disney pulled
the plug on would have created 2 000 new
jobs with an average salary of 120 a
year the median household income in
Florida is about 60
000. Giancarlo Sopo from Vista media
Visto media tweeted this uh the truth is
this project died the day chapik was
fired Iger hated it it was a terrible
idea it had already been delayed until
2026. those 2 000 jobs were California
transplants mostly of whom did not want
to move to Florida because creatives
like La this article called it in
November so back in November uh wow news
today which focuses on Disney had that
anyway let's get back to uh Alyssa Ferry
you'll see what we're doing here trust
me Alyssa Farah from The View saw that
from Giancarlo and she wrote This I
Believe Giancarlo is correct here but
the political problem is public
perception the governor picked a fight
and the State lost jobs and revenue she
continued having a major corporation
come out and say they left your state
because of the uncertain business
environment is a huge blow when one of
the biggest selling points on the right
is about the free state of Florida has
been about the free state of Florida has
been the business environment so you
have to understand here she's doing
exactly what everyone in corporate media
does she's lying about what the real
issue is it's not that Disney is not
friendly to business that Florida is not
friendly to business Florida started
taking away Disney's special rights so
if other states want to give certain
corporations special rights which
actually seems anti-constitutional to me
they can go ahead and do it but Florida
is going to have a even playing field
for everybody I don't like to do this so
sort of thing but every now and again I
have to dunk on somebody a slam dunkaroo
on the Twitter and I saw Alyssa's tweet
and I tweeted this
to Alyssa I retweeted her I said what
makes you a conservative or a republican
other than it pays well to pretend to be
one to be on The View DeSantis took
special rights away from Disney he got
rid of crony capitalism oh wait Disney
owns ABC which just so happens to be the
network you work for Whoopi enjoy we'll
trash the hell out of you once you're
fired right after the election by the
way hope it's worth it uh and of course
I followed up Alyssa Faris shuts off the
replies on her tweet so you're not
allowed to reply to her Alyssa it's
really not worth it have some
self-respect ask Megan McCain if she's
happier now you know I really do try not
to get into these little Twitter battles
but these people
I do it with corporate people if you're
a corporate mainstream hack then I will
go after you I try not to do it
generally speaking it's not like the
best use of time to be fighting with
people on Twitter but do you think it's
odd that she works at ABC Disney and
she's taking the position she is as a
conservative
[Music]